ELLEN WEST: I just wanted
to ask you what
drew you to this story?
Was it a personal experience,
or what was it about the
underlying story here that made
you want to make your
first non-documentary?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Well, all
three of those stories seemed
like they could be interesting
documentaries.
And all three of those things
are based on things that are
happening every day.
I'm sorry you were
freaked out.
I love hearing when people say,
oh, it makes me want to
reach out and tell someone that
I miss them or love them,
like when you have a dream, a
bad dream, and you wake up,
and you suddenly inexplicably
want to call your mother or
sister, and they find it strange
that you're calling.
I like that.
I like that effect.
ELLEN WEST: I mean, it does
have that effect.
But it just makes me wonder.
And I'm looking at at least one
other person I know who is
a parent here in the audience
of all the times we spend in
our house, everybody on their
own device, and it really does
resonate in that way.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Yeah, I mean,
I don't think being on a
device is bad.
I think it can just,
like, we have two
parallel realities now.
We used to have just one,
the physical world.
And now there's another one.
And I think that other
one is very exciting.
We're all dealing with
how much should we be
in that other one.
I mean, 50 years ago, I don't
think there were 1,000 people
you could talk to in a second.
You couldn't.
You had to just sort of
hang out with the
person in front of you.
And now that you have the choice
of 1,000 other people,
if that, more, who can I talk
to now, I can talk to
anyone right now.
It's sort of tough to make those
decisions every minute
of every day.
Where do you put your focus?
So I think it's a
challenge, but
it's an exciting challenge.
ELLEN WEST: And did you help
work on the script and do
research for it, and how did you
develop these storylines?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: So the stories
were sort of inspired
from real live events
by Andrew Stern.
And he fictionalized them.
And then me, not knowing how
to make a fiction movie,
really, I just set about it like
I would a documentary.
So I interviewed a lot of people
that went through all
these things.
I went through--
I interviewed people who had
gotten their identity stolen.
And I interviewed people who
had worked on pornographic
chat sites.
And I interviewed people who
were cyberbullies, one kid,
actually, only.
And I interviewed FBI agents and
a cyber crimes detective
from New York City.
And I put all these people in
front of my actors, in case
they wanted to spend
time with them.
And that was very useful.
And once I really understood
what these people went
through, then we would go and
rewrite certain scenes in the
script to make them reflect
reality better.
So it's a sort of retroactive
documentary research that fed
back into the story lines.
That's how we did it.
ELLEN WEST: What a fantastic
group of actors you were able
to cast in the film.
How did you go about getting
word out about this film and
finding these people to bring
the characters to life?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Well,
the financier is an
unusually risky guy.
He just said to me and the
producer, just hire whoever
you think is good.
So we just went after people
that we liked.
Like, I had always loved Michael
Nyqvist, who has a
small role.
But he plays the guy in "The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo,"
in the Swedish film.
I love him.
He plays the journalist.
So let's put him the
movie somewhere.
And I've always loved
Jason Bateman.
I always thought he was a very
magnetic guy who you can
really relate to.
And I've never really
seen him do drama.
And when I asked him, he said,
thank you, no one asks me to
do drama, ever.
I wish people would.
So I had him grow a beard
so that you wouldn't
notice he was funny.
I was hoping that would help you
believe that it's someone
else, not the guy from "Arrested
Development." And
then other odd casting
choices, Marc Jacobs.
ELLEN WEST: I was going
to ask about that.
How did you convince him
to make his film debut,
particularly in a
role like that?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Yeah, he
doesn't really care what
anybody thinks, so he
just was up for it.
He thought it was funny,
a challenge.
He's a very brilliant, creative,
mind and always
looking for a challenge.
And I've known him for years.
And I actually had a friend who
was supposed to play this
role, the guy who
owns The Box.
I'm sure you've all
heard of The Box
down on Chrystie street.
His name is Simon Hammerstein.
And he seemed like a good fit.
And his wife told him
he wasn't allowed
to play that role.
So I was just racking my
brain for a few weeks.
And I came up with, maybe,
Marc Jacobs would like
to play that guy--
sort of bizarre thought.
It just crossed my brain,
and he said yes.
ELLEN WEST: So the internet as
sort of a source of deception,
or a facilitator of deception,
seems to be a big theme-- kind
of the distance that it allows
people to deceive others and
to be something that they're
actually not in real life, or
to project an alternate self.
I mean, do you think that's
different from
other forms of deception?
Is it just more faster?
Or what is it about the web and
technology, given that you
said you didn't consider this
an anti-technology film?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Yeah, I mean
the themes of deception and
identity and false identity are
definitely strong in this
piece of writing that
Andrew did.
But I also see other things that
are interesting that are
not necessarily negative.
I love the scene where Jason
Bateman is connecting to that
kid, and they're actually both
telling each other the truth
for the first time
in the movie.
They are being honest with each
other, though he thinks
he's speaking to a girl.
So I think that's a giant truth
of the internet, too, is
it can really connect you with
other people, like-minded
people, or people who are going
through what you're
going through.
I think it's incredibly
therapeutic and helpful.
And in that one scene, it
is, for both of them.
It's funny, you make a movie,
and you have no idea, really.
There's a lot of things
going on the film.
And I'm hoping that it's also
about people communicating,
and miscommunicating, and the
power of human relationships
at the end of the film, and that
you don't come away just
thinking, OK, well that's the
anti-technology film.
But if people walk away thinking
that, I have no
control over that.
But certainly, to make a movie,
a thriller, to make it
a dramatic thriller, we've got
to pull some stories out of
the world that are happening
right now that are dramatic
and have to do with deception.
In the case of the journalist
and the kid, I think that
theme was more about
exploitation.
I could relate to that,
being a documentarian.
You are always wondering whether
or not you are doing
the right thing by
shooting someone,
putting them on camera.
To me, that was less about
the internet, really.
And they just happened
to meet that way.
I see we have a question.
ELLEN WEST: We one
question here.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN:
That's exciting.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
sharing the film.
That was really powerful.
I thought it was great.
Just a question about
you personally.
On the spectrum of being
connected versus not
connected, or how digital
are you personally?
Are you always connected with
multiple devices, or are you
a, I don't even own a smartphone
type of person.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Yeah, I, like
all of you in this room,
struggle with how much time
I spend on my phone.
And I'm sure that's true down
to every last one of you.
And my friends, it's
the same question.
Like I said when I sat down,
who do you focus on, the
person in front of you, or the
10 people texting you?
It's such a hard decision,
especially when you love three
of those 10 people texting
you, and one of
them is your mother.
And you really have to get
back to your mother.
But yet, you're sitting
with your father.
And he's saying, stop,
get off your phone.
These are the questions
everyone's asking
themselves every day.
I don't think I'm alone.
I was not on Facebook
for a long time.
I am now.
And I only have 100 friends,
which people laugh at me.
But they are people I know.
I am on Instagram.
And I love Instagram.
That's a lot fun to just check
out where everybody is and
what they're doing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
ELLEN WEST: Over here?
AUDIENCE: So I agree with both
of you how the internet can be
a vehicle for dishonesty, in
new ways, and honesty as
well-- as illustrated so
well in that scene.
And I'm just curious, for you
personally, are you optimistic
or pessimistic about where these
technologies will take
us in terms of human
relations.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: I am
incredibly optimistic.
I probably shouldn't be.
I should be, like, the guy who
is saying get off your phone
because I made this movie.
But again, I didn't make this
movie because of a message
that some people think it has.
I made this movie because
it felt very real.
A lot of the questions and
things in it felt very real to
me and like things that I'm
struggling with myself.
I'm very, very optimistic.
I'm very excited about
Google Glass.
I think, for a filmmaker,
that is a radical thing.
Is that what it's called,
Google Glass?
ELLEN WEST: Yeah.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Like, I
could put on glasses?
I've waited my whole life, as
a filmmaker, for glasses I
could put on and film
everything.
I've always wanted a camera
in my eyeball.
But the things that are so hard
to get on film are those
intimate moments between
people where someone's
embarrassed, or someone's
showing emotion, or
someone's in danger.
That's when you put your camera
down as a filmmaker.
You feel, as a human,
you're like, I can't
possibly film this.
Someone's dying.
Or someone is crying.
Or someone's just had something
horrible happen.
Put the camera down.
If I'd had a camera in my
eyeball, I would have even
more beautiful scenes in the
film "Murderball." It would be
more intimacy.
So I'm excited for all those
moments that are going to be
captured in the future by
filmmakers using that
technology.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ELLEN WEST: We have
someone else here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I was curious in
the past how you've approached
the documentary subjects that
you've made, and then how this
experience of making a narrative
you think will
affect future movies, whether
those are narratives or
documentaries?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Personally?
For me?
AUDIENCE: Yes, you know how
you use the documentary
approach in this narrative?
If there's things that you
learned about the narrative
that you'd bring back if you're
making a documentary.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: It's funny you
say that because when my
partner Dana and I were making
"Murderball," we watched a lot
of sports films that we love,
movies like "Rudy" and
"Hoosiers" and "Rocky" and
"Miracle." And we were
determined to make a movie with
"Murderball" that would
feel like a fiction movie that
would suck you in, and had
music, and had shots,
and had sequences.
So it wouldn't feel like your
typical documentary that was
just zooming in on everything
from afar.
But now I did the exact opposite
with this film.
Everything was just
in front of me--
and usually, when you're
shooting a documentary, it's
always a struggle to just get
someone's face in focus.
And so I found myself getting
annoyed with all the control
that I had.
And I started shooting from
across the street, or shooting
through people.
And then it felt more
real to me.
It felt more like what I'm used
to seeing through a lens.
But there are a lot of rules on
set that I learned that are
very annoying, like, you're
supposed to say cut.
You don't say cut in
documentaries, OK?
You would never say that.
So I just ended up just letting
the camera roll a lot.
And what that was wonderful
about that was that it kept
the makeup artists, and the hair
people, and the booming
people with their mics, and the
guys tweaking the lights,
it kept them away.
Because when you're rolling,
they don't ever want
to be in the frame.
So they just stay at bay.
And then I could play.
And the actors could
do whatever and go
wherever they wanted.
And I shot most of this movie
with two cameras, which means
they could interrupt each other,
or they could play the
scene this way or that
way, you could
always cut it together.
And that was the way that I took
back control over the set
because the machinery of
moviemaking is really heavy.
There's cables everywhere, as
I'm sure you guys have seen.
Everything's contrived.
There's nothing real
about the process.
So what I would do, especially
with the kids, is I would move
the cameras back, far, and
sometimes, I would even put a
light, like there's a light my
face now, I would hit a light
towards them so they
couldn't even see
where the cameras were.
I did that quite a lot.
And then they would forget that
the cameras were even
filming them.
And I would say, go again,
go again, go again.
And by the fifth or sixth take,
they were just acting
like themselves--
clowns.
And then I got good footage.
ELLEN WEST: And how much of it
was, I mean, letting them--
sticking to the script and doing
variations on that, or
is it like Woody Allen?
Here's a general thing
of where we're
going in this scene.
And some big points we want to
hit, but leaving it up to the
actors to interpret their
characters and the situation.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Well, we
started with the script.
And then we got further
away from the script.
And I would just tell them
to do it in their words.
Sometimes, for certain scenes
that required more emotion, I
just wanted to see what they
would come up with.
Most directors, the idea of
directing is very aggressively
dominating and imposing your
will or viewpoint on people.
And I, because I come from
documentaries, thought of my
actors, well, they're real
people, they have instincts.
Let's see what they
do before I even
influence them in any direction.
Let's just see what their
instincts are.
And that's how I operated.
And then, if there were things
that I felt were fake or
needed correcting, then
I would step in.
But I never spoke
before a scene
because these are humans.
And these stories are human.
And let's see what they
come up with.
Let's see how they play it.
So in fact, if anything, I
found myself allowing the
actors to be more than telling
them what to do,
if that make sense.
ELLEN WEST: I just want to
switch gears a bit because in
looking at your bio and then
talking with you a bit before
we did this screening--
we're an advertising company,
which is, I mean, people don't
realize that Google is.
And looking at your resume and
the things you've done, I
mean, how do you go from making
a film like this, or
serious documentaries that
are so intense, to
doing Burger King?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Advertising
is really fun.
And I love it.
And I do it every day.
It's my day job.
And I really love trying to
make real things look
beautiful or make beautiful
things look more real.
That's a lot of the challenge
because so much of advertising
is so contrived.
And as you all know, nobody
wants to sit through
advertising.
So we're all trying to figure
out ways to not watch or not
listen to advertising.
So how do you get into that 1%
of ads that cut through?
I think the Google Glass
thing cut through.
It became more than
just an ad.
It became like news.
That's exciting,
ads like that.
And I've been involved in a lot
of campaigns like that,
that it felt like social
experiments.
Like I did Whopper Freakout,
where we took the Whopper off
the menu, and we filmed
people freaking out.
That was one of the ads I did.
Or I just did this Coca Cola
campaign where we went around
the world, and we really found
real people who do good.
And so there's a guy who
puts up swings in poor
neighborhoods all over.
And it just transforms
the neighborhood.
And that's what he does.
He's committed his
life to that.
And there's another girl who
plants trees in crap
neighborhoods that are
very industrial.
And there's another guy who
got rich off an insurance
company that he sold.
So he gives 1,000 pounds to
a stranger every day.
And he's been doing
it systematically
for, now, over a year.
And so we found these people.
And I got to interview them
and hang out with them.
Obviously, it's about selling
sweet water in the end.
But it was sort of a great
experience to put all these
people who do cool stuff
up on screen.
Those are the kinds
of ads I love.
ELLEN WEST: Cool, Brendan?
AUDIENCE: Hi, like to your point
you just mentioned, your
visual style has a very kind
of cinema verite approach.
Do you think that, going
forward with any future
non-documentary features you
make, or even a documentary,
do you think that you're sort
of stuck in your ways now?
You found a great niche.
And you know exactly what--
a Rubin movie is going
to look like this?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: I love
that, a Rubin movie.
That suggests that I'm going
to make another one.
Yes, I mean, I reverted, to tell
you the truth, being on
set, if I'm to be really honest,
I had no idea what I
was doing at first.
I'm very comfortable
with documentaries.
And the politics of fiction
film, and the hierarchy of the
crew, and all that, can be very
daunting and off-putting.
And everything is so contrived
in that atmosphere of a set
that getting into place, a
safe place, where you can
allow actors to feel safe and
be real is a huge challenge.
It's much easier to do it in
a documentary form because
people are just living in the
world, and you're just
sneaking around zooming
in on them.
I prefer that.
I reverted to that making this
movie, to that way of being.
So yes, I think I have a way
that I feel comfortable
shooting things and I'm
going to stick to it.
ELLEN WEST: So we won't be
seeing you make "Iron Man 4"?
No?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: I
don't think so.
I don't think I would do well
making a movie like that.
I think it would look really
strange and eavesdropped.
I'm not sure it would
look good.
I don't know.
Plus, I think those movies are
fun, but they're not what I'm
interested in.
I love the idea, whether it's a
documentary or an ad that's
60 seconds or a fiction movie,
really, what's the most
exciting thing for a filmmaker,
for me, is emotion.
And if you can get that, if you
can create that in 60 or
90 seconds, and you can create
that at the end of a fiction
movie, then that's exciting.
That's the stuff that sort
of gets under your skin.
That's the stuff that you think
about two days from now.
All that other stuff is noise.
There's so much noise
out there.
I think it's, for me, at least
in my experience, it's when I
feel something that
I remember it.
ELLEN WEST: So do you have a
next project that you're
starting, in the middle of?
I mean, how does the process
work for you?
This is now out and getting
a great reception.
So what do you do next?
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: I'm about to
do to Spain, where I'm going
to paint a Volvo truck red,
bright red, and then we're
going to send it through
Pamplona with the bulls
chasing it.
And we're going to see if this
driver can handle all the
turns on the bull run.
And we're going to
do it for real.
So that'll be fun.
So I'm leaving tomorrow
to shoot that.
ELLEN WEST: We want to thank
you again for coming and
sharing your film with us
on a Friday afternoon.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Thank you.
Thanks for staying, you guys.
ELLEN WEST: And good luck
with the Volvo.
HENRY ALEX RUBIN: Thank you.